it has been quite a while since I did a
new meme Roundup and commentary so it's
about time for me to look at a few of
the ones that people have sent my way
there may be more out there and I'll
talk about that later so here are two of
them right off the bat that I got a big
kick out of first one one of the latest
memes me deleting pics of friends and
family to make room for the Sadler
lectures podcast now the funny thing
about that of course is that since their
podcast episodes you'd really have to be
starved for space in order to have to
get rid of things on your phone in order
to be able to listen to the Sadler's
lectures podcast even though there are
900 episodes out there at this point I
think you could still fit them in but it
shows a certain dedication the other one
this is really quite funny went out with
a guy and he gave me his phone to pick
the playlist in the car he had a
playlist called sexy time so I naturally
chose that one it was nine hours of
non-stop Dr Gregory B Sandler walking
through the phenomenology of spirit in
helpful half hour chunks we are going
out again tomorrow now if you find
somebody who shares a love of the half
hour Hegel project and commentary videos
I think that's probably a keeper odds of
that happening pretty low
and we're going to see there's a lot of
other half hour Hegel memes this is
another really funny one what are you
doing why would you want to spend time
trying to understand Hegel quit having
fun so they're using this format and you
notice that there's quite a few there's
four of them sitting around watching a
half hour Hegel video this is another
great one based on that Meme of what's
on the guy's phone when she's like
looking over wondering what's there and
it's half our Eagle I appreciate the
dedication that it takes to put the not
just a video but the playlist in there
we move on to the next ones uh here we
start getting a bit more racy we've got
a cat girl with VR glasses and gloves
and all sorts of other things on saying
babe please I need to go for a walk but
unfortunately the guy is watching
you know my my half hour Hegel video and
it says later Greg's finally on
paragraph 787 of phenomenology of spirit
which is one that I did recently and
then we get this other funny one and I'm
sure you've seen the meme for this a guy
brings a woman to what looks like a
motel or hotel room and they're getting
ready to get it on and unfortunately
half our Hegel from self-consciousness
is on the TV so he doesn't take his
clothes off and she just goes to bed and
he sits there on the bed watching it we
move on to two other very funny memes
that were created first one you've
probably seen this format my grandfather
told me about Elvis Presley my father
told me about Michael Jackson I will
tell my kids about half hour Hegel well
I'm I'm very flattered by that I doubt
that's going to happen and then we have
this picture of Joe Biden the president
of America looking at the TV grinning
and it's a me looking at the chalkboard
not quite sure what video that is from
and we continue on with more half hour
Hegel once again we got a good one with
a playlist
and some headphones on a pregnant
woman's belly I told her it was Mozart
because that's supposed to make you
smart but instead he's playing me
chattering on about Hegel and then
finally we get this funny banana meme
when my parents come into my room I just
switch to our hentai because it's easier
to explain so you know racy images
rather than trying to have your parents
understand you watching the half hour
Hegel Series so that's a lot of Hegel
now we get to some other things about my
YouTube channel more broadly
we've got this uh interesting one who's
coming from Zoolander I think you
probably know my normal bedtime right
which is uh Zoolander himself if I'm not
mistaken and then we have his great
rival whose Name Escapes Me Right Now
the rabbit hole of Greg Sadler's YouTube
channel the idea is that you're
foregoing what you should be doing and
not letting yourself sleep at night we
have another great one here you your
philosophy professors lecture your
videos this kid behind holding up a rose
and just a a hand and an arm Greg
Sadler's YouTube channel so what does
that imply people aren't really watching
their professors YouTube videos instead
they're going over to my channel there
was also this big thing that was going
on for a while of what celebrity would
play you in a biopic and so we got you
know Jeff Bridges is Gregory Sadler I
kind of like that one we do look a bit
alike weirdly enough you know who I'm
getting these days that people are
bringing up and I don't actually see the
resemblance but my wife does
Christian Bale we come to the last of
the memes and I had to actually ask
people what the hell is going on here
because I haven't seen the movie that
this is referencing I guess they're
having a psychedelic trip and so we've
got Gregory Sadler Mia's Nick Cage and
then uh person sharing a meme with a
fake quote from an ancient philosopher
cage is being serious this other guy is
laughing his balls off and uh yeah I I'm
I guess known at this point for going
after people who are sharing fake quotes
so they made a meme out of that last
thing I got to say about all of this is
if you see something say something and
what I mean by that is let me know if
you see new memes of me and I will post
them on my various social media provided
they're not you know too over the line
and I'll put them into the next meme
video video this might be an impetus to
some people to make some new memes I'm
always happy to see what they are I will
say as well that my wife also gets a
kick out of these so that's all for this
installation of the New Meme Roundup and
commentary